quand on regarde on donne pour moi on me
dit c'est un garçon normal il est
parfait il a pas de problème pourquoi
vous voulez trouver des problèmes
physiques
je veux pas trouver des problèmes j -
les problèmes je les vois tous les jours
à la maison vous voyez pas sur la caméra
mais comme vous voyez sur la porte du
des enfants ici il ya des papiers collés
partout pour justement essayer qui
n'oublie pas qu'il oublie pas de quand
ils se lèvent qu'il faut qu'ils brossent
les dents qui se douche qui quand il
enlève ses vêtements qui doit aller
ramasser les mettre dans un panier qui
doivent laver tous les jours quand il
prend quelque chose là qu'il redépose là
où il apprit à l'heure actuelle toutes
vos paris ah oui maintenant c'est comme
ça c'est c'est tous les jours comme ça
c'est pour moi c'est tous les jours
comme si je pouvais enregistre une
cassette qui répètent les choses les
mêmes choses tous les jours tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours au
début on se disait peut-être qu'il le
fait exprès et tout mais au bout d'un
moment on voit que c'est pas fait exprès
et il ya un moment aussi où il a un
coupure il ya une coupure avec ce monde
il ya pendant 10-15 minutes tu sais
comme s'il est dans les nuages
là il faut venir et le le bousculer pas
le bousculer pour faire marrer mais sur
le faire revenir
brandon revient arrivé en ce2 je re et
je retourne voir le professeur toujours
avec mon discours en début de rentrée
scolaire
et là je dis aux profs duparay y goûter
brandon aura des difficultés vous allez
voir il sait pas ne sait pas lire et
confond les led et connaissait pas ses
syllabes
il sait pas écrire au début on avait mis
ça sur le dos il est né en angleterre sa
première langue s'est d'emblée c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'il est en retard
bas longtemps et là on me dit
effectivement en ce2 qui devrait être
placée en clis hockey
c'est quoi la crise on me dit ben voilà
c'est une des classes où ils sont peu
d'élèves pour des élèves ou qui ont des
difficultés
l'orthophoniste voit effectivement que
brandon a des gros soucis que pour son
âge il ya qu un niveau d' enfants de cp
sainement chose qui n'est pas normal
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on sait pas pourquoi on sait
pas c'est quoi le problème
j'aimerais bien savoir le problème et du
coup ça joue surtout sur ses émotions
surtout donc j'aimerais bien savoir voir
des professionnels pour qu'on me dise ce
qui se passe c'est là qu'elle n'a envoyé
vers le dr doré effectivement il ya des
soucis il faudrait approfondir
approfondir voir d'où vient le problème
parce qu'effectivement ça se voit qu'il
a un gros souci mon ans quand on
reconnaît qu'il ya un problème
ah oui mais on ne sait pas on s'est
passé quoi là les causes on les trouve
non non au bout d'un moment on en a
marre on en a marre puisque on se dit on
finit par croire que c'est vraiment
notre casque qui est le problème
du coup le problème que lui là bas ça
joue sur nous aussi parce qu'un bout
d'un moment on n'en peut plus on n'en
peut plus on se dit que non c'est pas la
faute au début on se dit ah c'est pas la
faute de notre fils mais à force
d'entendre que c'est lui c'est lui c'est
lui on finit par se dire c'est que
vraiment le problème en fait la société
qui nous entoure
involontairement nous amène à détester
lagos donc ça fait un an que vous servez
le prouver
on commence à cerner le problème douze
ans après tout et on recommence à je
commence à avoir un comprendre ce que ce
qu'il a enfin on ne sait pas encore mais
on commence à me dire que bon déjà que
c'est sûr il va la voir toute sa vie
maintenant c'est comme ça et que ça
passe va pas changer ça peut changer
il aura ce retard là toute sa vie le
problème n'est pas génétique puisque
justement commencent à s'intéresser à la
grossesse et c'est là qu'on voit que
effectivement il ya eu huit mois où il
ya eu de l'alcool il avait débordé
des médicaments et du coup là où on
entre vraiment dans le problème où ils
se disent que ben voilà ça pour pas avec
les sous les problèmes qu'il a le retard
qu'il a ça se pointe fur et à mesure ça
se précise
et du coup c'est là qu'on comprend qu'on
compte qu'on reçoit la vérité en pleine
figure en fait et qu'est ce qu'on vous
dit ferme en bas le docteur murray a été
a été très bien puisque du coup est là
elle a pris des termes médicaux
donc du coup pourrait c'est
l'alcoolisation foetale
mais c'est vrai que en tant que maman
nomme si on utilise des termes médicaux
ça reste quand même un problème puisque
du coup à la base on se dit on à pas
comment j'ai pas inconnu ma grossesse
d'une aujourd'hui mon fils il a deux ans
j'ai suivi son problème de vie avec son
problème et tout d'un coup même si on ne
le dit pas même si on me dit que c'est
pas moi on vous point on vous dit à le
problème vient de là donc du coup là on
l'a on reçoit la grosse claque
on reçoit la grosse cote parce qu'on se
dit c'est de ma faute si j'avais pas vu
si j'avais pas pris les médicaments
s'ils avaient veut pas tout ça mon gosse
très normal serait comme tout le monde
et c'est vrai que mal si on essaie de
vous rassurer on enlèvera jamais ce côté
de culpabilité en fait on enlèvera
jamais puisque du coup on s'est dit on
se pose plein de questions pourquoi
pourquoi j'ai pas senti cette grossesse
pourquoi je n'ai pas j'ai pas vu ce bébé
du pas senti ce bébé bouger pourquoi
donc à toutes ces questions et après on
voit les difficultés qu'il a on voit
qu'en qui a du mal à s'intégrer on voit
que les autres le regardent le juge
du coup c'est cesser toutes les douleurs
que moi que ce que sa famille on reçoit
donc du coup tous les soirs quand on
rend chez soi il ya tout ce poids se
croisent de dire que
si seulement j'avais su ça serait pas
arrivé on demande pas que le côté
professionnel
on demande le côté humain parce qu'un
professionnel et travailler avec ces
enfants là pour moi c'est avant tout
d'être humains d'écouté de excusez moi
mais ce que j'ai apprécié avec elle
c'est que quand je vais parler
elle a mis de côté les papiers et la
seule chose qu'elle a demandé à mon fils
déjà pour voir vraiment le souci c'était
un truc simple bien donner un papier un
stylo
il l'a dit et écrit moi ce que tu veux
ce qui passe par la tête
je suis pas là pour te corriger je suis
pas là pour juger mais écrit moi ce que
tu veux
chose que j'ai apprécié et on a continué
la discussion sera autre chose mais en
regardant le papier elle a vu que qu'il
a écrit n'avait rien n'avait pas de sens
hélas elle voit que en fait il sait pas
écrire et l'ubo gentiment mais tu as
voulu dire quoi il a juste voulu écrire
qu'il aimait le collège passer du temps
avec l'enfant essayer de voir ce qui ne
va pas je vous jure et vous allez
comprendre beaucoup de choses
le problème peut il le voit une heure
nous on le voit 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24 je dis pas qu'on est spécialisée
mais on peut les aider à avancer dans la
recherche puisque c'est le problème il
est là tous les jours eux ils le voient
que sur un rendez vous aujourd'hui et
dans l'adolescence
hyland à l'adolescence et dans sa tête
il a la mentalité et le niveau d'un
enfant de 6 ans 5 6 ans
donc en tant que maman est ce que je dis
au collège est ce que je dis temps avec
tous les professionnels quand il a 18
ans il devient quoi
eelv on fait quoi avec lui 6 à 18 ans il
a je sais pas moi il n'a pas le niveau
non plus d'un enfant de dix huit ans
vous allez faire quoi de mon fils on va
le mettre où demain moi je n'ai pas
encore expliqué que aujourd'hui s'il est
comme ça c'est parce que voilà quand
j'étais enceinte j'ai fait ça j'ai fait
ça de moi est ce qu'ils se sont posé la
question comment lui va prendre la chose
comment gérer ce que lui va penser moi
j'ai déjà épongé déjà pensé à ça parce
que moi je sais que maintenant il va se
retourner contre moi même si c'est pas
moi mais est ce que eux ils ont foncé à
ce côté là est ce que cette vérité là va
faire sur lui dans son cerveau donc
voyez c'est des questions que moi je me
dis est ce que il se pose c'est bien de
savoir ce qu'il a mais l'impact que ça
va avoir
est ce qui le plus ils le cherchent à
savoir ça aujourd'hui je suis arrivé à
un point où j'arrive à pas à boire un
verre
aujourd'hui ça m'arrive
oui un verre mais c'est rare très très
rare aujourd'hui
buvez de l'eau il ya des cocktails sans
alcool un an
prenez les cocktails sans alcool c'est
pareil voilà je sais pas trouver autre
chose parce qu'aujourd'hui moi je sais
que les problèmes ça fait sur un gosse
gelé tous les jours et croyez moi ça
fait mal ça fait extrêmement mal
donc le fait plus écoutez ça le fait
plus ben ali
et puis les vendeurs même les magasins à
une fille ensemble qui a acheté de
l'alcool
non le fait pas le vendait pas cette
fille là parce que vous êtes part de ce
problème après donc même les les grandes
surfaces je sais que c'est votre boulot
je sais que les petits magasins vous
vivez de ça mais il ya un peu de
conscience
quand vous voyez une femme qui rentre
une jeune fille qui rompt qui est
enceinte qui vous achète de l'alcool lui
vendez pas de l'alcool
parce que demain vous allez revoir son
gosse et s'il a un problème si vous êtes
un minimum humain vous avez vous dit
rien c'est un peu de ma faute aussi
parce que je les laissais prendre cette
bouteille l'affût mois donc le fait pas
non plus voilà c'est tout